the abc sitcom the middle began with two
tv comedy veterans in the lead roles
namely patricia heaton and neil flynn
prior to the middle
heaton was best known for her role as
deborah barone in the classic sitcom
everybody loves raymond while neil flynn
had his own fans from his role as the
janitor in scrubs
while viewers initially tuned in to see
how these performers would do in a new
show that was reminiscent of their prior
roles
the middle soon set itself apart on its
own merits
the show focused on the trials and
tribulations of the heck family
which consisted of mom frankie heck
played by heaton
and dad mike heck played by flynn the
couple had three children played by
charlie mcdermott
eden cher and atticus schaefer all of
whom became integral to the show's
success
mcdermott in particular caught the
attention of the show's fans as eldest
son
axel heck and many of the show's viewers
were eager to see where his career would
go when the show wrapped up its run in
2018
however mcdermott hasn't been seen much
on screen recently
i've worked too hard being too awesome
and sue is not gonna drag me down to
dorkdom with her i'm out i put my foot
down
i'm not driving her anymore viewers
weren't the only people who wondered
what life after axel heck would look
like
from the beginning of the middle the
show's end loomed large in mcdermott's
thoughts
in 2017 the actor told sioux city
journal that he felt like his time on
the series could
quote fall apart at any time he
especially feared that when it all
finally crumbled
he would be trapped under the lovable
rubble of his character
as he put it i'm honestly very terrified
this show will end
and everyone will like me as an actor
but no one will ever hire me because i
look like axel
mcdermott hasn't been completely absent
from acting since the end of the middle
after the series ended he popped up in
the 2018 comedy
instant family as stewart a co-worker of
mark wahlberg's character pete
he also showed up in the netflix drama
unbelievable
as ty a counselor at the oakdale
apartment complex
where marie adler played by caitlin
deaver is staying
mcdermott later returned to the big
screen in the horror movie countdown
playing scott a fellow nurse at the
hospital where elizabeth lale's quinn
works
very notably these have all been
supporting roles though mcdermott has
proven his willingness to explore
genres in the process unfortunately
2019's countdown
horrified some critics in all the wrong
ways
on rotten tomatoes the film received a
score of 26 percent among critics
who felt that countdown wouldn't quote
leave a lasting impression
luckily that's not the last impression
mcdermott will leave on his fans
while critics look down on countdown
mcdermott isn't down for the count
creatively
he has shown an interest in both
photography and drawing
posting both on instagram but it's music
that his focus appears to have turned to
in 2020 mcdermott began releasing his
own original songs
in october he released a music video for
his song wayside
followed by music videos for his songs
bake a cake
and butterfingers all of this culminated
in the release of his 8-track album
titled some things just fall out of your
hands
in november 2020 the music and the
videos take you on a trippy odyssey
wayside for instance combines haunting
vocals and visuals as mcdermott toils
alone in the woods
and seemingly awaits nightly visits from
a ghostly figure or
figment of his mind bake a cake
wordlessly presents scenes of city life
and nature in an almost
nervous time lapse the album's dreamy
almost
fairytale tone led to glowing reviews
from fans on social media who connected
with the material
mcdermott is far from the first person
to pursue a career both in acting
and music so the release of the album
does not rule out his return to acting
in the future
as the middle prepared for its swan song
in 2017
he told the philadelphia inquirer i
would like to keep acting
but acting is so spontaneous hollywood
is a tricky business where plans fall
out of your hands
so only time will tell what the heck
comes next for mcdermott
until then however his album can be
found on bandcamp
spotify and apple music check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite tv stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one